apple just did something that broke the  tech side of the internet they announced  their self-service repair program  finally allowing regular people to order  genuine apple parts to fix their own  devices this new program is also very  good news for independent repair shops  that will now have access to apple  service manuals and genuine parts i want  to get into why it's actually apple who  is the real winner in this situation i  fully believe that apple is finally  trying to repair their brand image apple  is preparing to launch their own vr  headset as soon as next year potentially  alongside their own version of a  metaverse so if they want to gain the  trust of millions of customers they need  to start doing it now another reason is  that apple is probably sick and tired of  being sued all the time for their  repairability issues but the beautiful  thing about all of this is that it's  essentially a win-win for everyone